The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from 100 of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HONG LIU: OK, good.
So let me first remind
you what we did last time.
So last time we discussed
that, for any operator,
say some operator O
in the field theory,
we expect this one to one
correspondence to some field,
say, phi in the gravity side.
And of course, the
quantum numbers of those,
they should match because of
the four [? interpretations ?]
of some symmetry groups and
four [? interpretations ?]
of the same symmetry groups.
Of course, their quantum
numbers should also match.
And, in particular, on
the field theory side,
say if you have
such an operator,
it's natural to
add the source term
and then to deform the
Lagrangian in such a form.
And then we explained
that, this phi
may be considered as the
boundary value of phi
in the boundary of ADS.
So the boundary value of phi,
and it's mapped to the-- if phi
have some boundary
value, then that
is corresponding to
your boundary series
Lagrangian have such a term.
You know, Lagrangian.
And then we also discussed
this for the vector field,
and for conserved
current, say, the case
which is a conserved
current, then
that implies that, in a
particular example of this,
if you have a conserved current
that that's corresponding to,
you must be dual
to a gate field.
And in particular,
the stress tensor
must be to dual to the magic
deformation in the field series
site.
So any questions regarding this?
Good.
OK.
So now let's try to
develop more this relation.
So this is normally called
the operator field mapping.
And so let's look at this
relation a little bit more.
So my immediate
question, one can
ask-- so the obvious
question is regarding,
say, the spin of
the operator that
should map to the spin of
this operator, et cetera.
But if you can see the conformal
theory, which is the scaling
variant, a very
important quantum number
for scaling operator is
the scaling dimension.
As we mentioned before, we
said, in the conformal theory,
everything is scaling variant.
And then you can
assign any operator--
any operator can
be transform under
appropriate representation
of the conformal symmetry
of the scaling dimension.
That's one of the most
important quantum numbers.
So now let's look
at how the scaling
dimension of this
operator are related
to the physical properties here.
Because here, there
is no low scaling
dimension in the sense this
is just some gravity field
and here is isometric it's
not the scaling symmetry.
And then we also can
try to understand
the worries of properties
of this phi, how
they are reflected
in O. So that's
the purpose of today's lecture.
So for this purpose, now,
let's look at the gravity side.
So as we said last
time, we always
work in the regime of the
semiclassical gravity.
So on the gravity side-- OK.
So what we will show is
that, actually, the dimension
of this operator can
be directly related
to the mass of the corresponding
field in the gravity site.
And so this is normally called
a mass dimension relation.
So now let's just consider,
on the gravity side,
so the action can generically
be written as the following.
So everything is controlled by
the gravitational interaction.
So now I have introduced a new
rotation, which we explain.
So you have Einstein gravity.
And then you have
some matter fields.
OK?
You have some matter fields.
Matter Lagrangian.
So this is the
generic form, say,
of action in the gravity side.
So I've introduced this 2 kappa
squared, which is essentially
whatever is the Newton constant
in this d plus one dimension.
So normally we put the 6
pi G Newton constant here.
So d plus 1 just
means the Newton
constant in d plus 1 dimension.
And I just now called this 2
kappa squared for convenience.
And typically, the
matter fields, say,
suppose you have a
scalar field, then
you will have-- say for inform,
plus, say, nonlinear terms.
And if you have, say, if
you have vector fields,
then you will have a
Maxwell actions, et cetera.
So just whatever matter field
you have in the gravity side,
and they just have
this-- so now let's
consider small perturbations
around the pure AdS.
So pure AdS, you
only have a metric,
and all the matter field
is essentially zero.
So now let's consider the small
perturbations around the AdS.
Or maybe I should
say around the AdS.
So first thing you notice is
that these 2 kappa squared
is multiplied over all action.
So that means that all the
interactions here, essentially,
are controlled by this
gravitational interaction.
Yeah, it's all
controlled by kappa.
And when you can see the
small perturbations, say,
when you can quantize the
small perturbations, et cetera,
it's convenient to use a
canonically normalized action.
But if you look at
the matter field here,
the [INAUDIBLE] is this
1 over 2 kappa squared,
which is a lot convenient.
Actually, with that 2,
then I don't need 2 here.
So let me just get rid of the 2.
So it's convenient to use a
canonically normalized action.
So it's considered a small
[INAUDIBLE] around AdS,
say, for convenient
to canonically.
normalize.
AUDIENCE: Excuse me, why--
HONG LIU: Yeah, one second.
Normalize the kinetic term
of small perturbations.
OK?
Which means it's convenient
when we can see, say,
for example the series for
phi, when we consider scaling,
they take phi-- say k, phi
equal to kappa phi prime,
and then you can see
that in the phi prime,
we'll have a canonical action.
And say, for example, if you
can see the magic perturbations,
and then you can
write it as hmn.
So this is the AdS matrix.
OK?
Then the phi prime and hmn
will be canonically normalized.
So later, we'll just
drop this prime.
I will just call this phi.
So we just do a
scaling operation.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why did the 1 over 2?
HONG LIU: Oh no, it's just
because there is 1 over 2 here.
AUDIENCE: But what
path, you have r--
you say the r is in the
action and r should--
HONG LIU: No, I'm talking
about the matter field.
AUDIENCE: But in the action,
you write the r minus 2
and the plus [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So ordinarily,
should it be r plus 1 over 2
[INAUDIBLE] something else?
HONG LIU: It doesn't matter.
It's just how I
normalized things.
You can normalize-- if
you worry about the 1/2,
it doesn't matter.
Here we're not
worried about 1/2.
AUDIENCE: OK.
HONG LIU: Good?
So now here's the
important point.
So here is the important point.
And remember, when we have the
relation between the Newton
constants, so the Kappa
squared is a Newton constant.
And remember, this is
proportional to our n squared.
Remember what we
discussed last time.
So that means,
under this scaling,
so kappa is actually
of all the 1 over n,
kappa is the Newton
constant it's
a square of Newton constant.
It's very small.
So this is in units
of literature.
And we always can see
that in the large N image
so that the Newton
constant is small.
And so this is small.
So in this regime,
if we keep phi--
so for canonically
normalized field, say,
if [INAUDIBLE] hmn
are of order 1,
then their perturbation
is naturally small.
Then their perturbation
is naturally small
because they are essentially
controlled by the kappa.
And it also means, if you
plug this into the action,
so it expands also
long linear terms.
So it also means
that nonlinear terms
are order kappa or higher.
So this is very
easy to understand.
So let's consider, say, phi
cubed term come from here.
So previously, we have
1 over kappa squared,
phi cubed term, so
after this scaling,
then I just have
kappa phi cubed.
So for phi of all the
1, then the cubic term
will be suppressed compared
to the quadratic term
because the quadratic
term, after the scaling,
will be of all the
1, will be all the 1.
So the lambda near term
will be suppressed or higher
and suppressed.
So except if we are
interested in considering
the contribution of
those higher order terms,
then to leading order, we
can actually just consider,
for small fluctuations,
we can just
consider the quadratic action.
This means that
to leading order?
So we can consider
the quadratic action.
So this means we can just-- so
this corresponding to quantize
the free series, OK?
So this corresponding to
quantize the free series.
Remember, we always
use h bar equal to 1.
So for those matter fields,
h bar is always equal to one.
And after you do the scaling
to get rid of the kappa,
we just treat them as the free
field theory quantization.
Good?
Any questions about this?
So now let's look at scalar
fields, just for illustration.
Let's look at what's the
behavior of a massive scalar
field.
So now let's consider
a massive scalar field.
for illustration.
And we consider some scalar
field phi in the [? back, ?]
which is due to some scalar
operator O in the boundary.
Just imagine.
OK?
So now let's consider the
quadratic action for phi.
So we can write down
the quadratic action.
So after you have
scaled out this kappa,
and the quadratic action
can be written explicitly
as the following across
all the kappa terms.
So this is just a free action.
And of the GMA, just the AdS.
So the quadratic order, this
just in the background AdS.
So we'll use this notation
to denote the [INAUDIBLE]
component of AdS.
So we're most of the
time using this metric.
This is my background
AdS metric.
And this is my action.
So we'll also use
of the notation
that the x m actually, I
should write this matrix here,
but it doesn't matter.
The x m should be
considered as z x mu.
And x mu is the coordinates
parallel to the boundary.
So do you remember how to
quantize the free field series
action?
So this is the time we
need to remember that.
So the first thing is how you
solve the equation motion.
So we actually don't
need to go to details.
I will just mention a
few important features.
OK, so this is just the
standard [INAUDIBLE] equation
for massive scalar fields
in the curved spacetime.
And this gMN is just
given by this metric.
So this is a
seemingly complicated
partial differential equation.
But here we have
lots of symmetry.
So there is a translational
symmetry along the directions
parallel to the boundary.
Then we can just write
down a Fourier transform.
So because of the translation
symmetries in x mu directions.
So we can just do a
Fourier transform.
We can write phi z x mu
in terms of, say, DDK.
So this k.x is just the
standard Minkowski contraction
because of the t and x part.
And essentially it's
slightly a Minkowski metric.
So [INAUDIBLE] here, k.x is
just the standard Minkowski
contraction.
So now it's the first transform.
Then you just plug this in.
Then this is very
easy to write down.
The only derivative now would
be just in the z direction.
Because then all the
derivatives in the t and x
can be replaced by k.
And then the equation
becomes very simple.
So it takes you a couple of
seconds to write it down.
So let me just write it down.
So it can be written
in the following form.
And then the k squared
just is the standard one.
Again, the k squared is
just as the standard Lorentz
contraction.
So omega would be the k
zero in the time direction.
We're just do the standard
Lorentz contraction.
So k mu.
So now, this equation can
actually be solved exactly.
So normally, when
you quantize it,
you solve the
equation motion, then
you find the complete
basis of solutions.
Then you expand in terms
of that complete the basis,
the co-option of the expansion
would be your creation
and annihilation operators.
And then that's how you
quantize this series.
So this equation can
actually be solved exactly.
So you can actually easily find
out the complete set of modes.
But it would be
actually not needed
for the current
purpose right now.
So maybe not solve it.
So we'll leave it here.
But what will be
important for us
is consider the symptotic
behavior of the phi,
the phi near the boundary.
Now, let's consider
the behavior of a phi
near the boundary, which will
be very important for us.
Now let's just consider behavior
of phi near the boundary.
So near the boundary,
z goes to 0.
So this term
compared to this term
is always much smaller
because z goes to 0.
m squared R squared is finite.
So we can drop this term.
But kinetic term, typically,
cannot drop because kinetic
term depends on 1.
So we just throw away this term.
So as z goes to 0,
and maybe also expand
this term more explicitly.
Then what you find,
just drop this term
and then write in this
term more explicitly.
Then you find the equation
can written as following.
So this is only valid when z
equals to 0, leading order.
So now this is equation
has a very nice form
because this equation
is homogeneous.
So z squared, then
the partial z squared,
z partial z, and then
you have this thing
which there's no derivative.
And so this is
not in some sense,
homogeneous in the derivative.
Such kind of equation
you can always
solve it by some power of z.
So this just write down answers.
So assuming phi is
proportional z to some power.
And this power, let
me call it delta.
So you plug these answers
into this equation,
then you get
[INAUDIBLE] equation.
So you can easily see,
from first term, you
get delta, delta minus 1.
From the second equation, you
get 1 minus d times delta,
m squared r squared.
And this is a simple
quadratic equation now
you can immediately solve.
So you found two solutions.
Find two solutions.
So we are writing this in
the form 1/2 d plus minus nu.
I will define this thing to be
my nu, so this is definition.
So I will introduce
the following notation.
I will take the plus sign.
I call the plus sign delta.
So from now on, delta
refers to plus sign.
And sometimes I use
the notation called
delta minus, which is
the minus sign, which
is also equal to d minus delta.
So this is the definition.
So now I use this
as the definition.
So from now on,
my delta is always
d divided by 2 plus this number.
So now what we have
found is that as z
go to 0, what we have found
is that as z goes to 0,
that destabilizes.
So as z goes to 0, the phi kz
has the following behavior.
So you have two
independent solutions.
So then I can put
arbitrary [INAUDIBLE],
z d minus delta to
exponents, and another one
is Bk z to the delta.
Then plus have all
the corrections.
OK?
So this is two leading behaviors
in z goes to the zero limit.
And of course, I can also
go to the coordinate space.
Then this is just the x, z,
which is Ax x z d minus OK?
So first notice that this
exponent, this d minus delta
exponent is always
smaller than delta.
So this term always dominates.
So this is the leading behavior.
And this is the
sub-leading behavior.
So keep this in mind.
So now we have found the
fourth symptotic behavior
of the solutions.
And now we can discuss physics.
Now we can discuss some physics.
Now let me make remarks.
For the first remark--
any questions so far?
Good.
So the first remark, you
notice that this exponent
are real if m squared R
squared greater than d minus 4.
Then you say, ah, for sure,
these exponents are all real.
Because normally,
we only consider
the positive mass squared.
But [INAUDIBLE] idea is
something very interesting
happening.
It's actually, in AdS,
the [INAUDIBLE] mass
squared also makes sense.
In fact, you can show, as far
as those exponents are real,
means that, as
far as, so one can
show, as far as the
star is satisfied,
the theory is
actually well defined.
So in AdS, you
are now-- you have
an [INAUDIBLE] mass squared.
But if you violated this,
then you find instability.
This is a very nice story,
but I don't have time
to discuss in detail here.
But my former student
[? Nabil Ackbar ?],
when he was doing
TA for me last time,
he wrote a very nice note
explaining how this works.
And I put that note on the web.
So this equation is
called the BF bound.
F is of our colleague Freedman.
And the B is a very complicated
name I always pronounced wrong.
So maybe not try here.
Anyway, so [? Nabil ?] gave
a very nice explanation
of where this comes from.
And he shows that
when you violate this,
you actually get instability.
And this maps into a very
nice quantum mechanics
problem, the quantum
mechanics problem of minus 1
over x squared.
Some of you may have
experience with that problem.
Anyway, so please
take a look at those.
I put it on the web.
And it's a very
instructive discussion.
But we'll take a
lecture to do that.
Anyway, so now I
just make the claim.
It's that, as far as
those exponents are real,
the theory's well defined.
OK?
But if this exponent
is violated,
then there exist modes
which are exponentially
growing in time indicating
the system in unstable.
So this star is
called the BF bound.
The BF bound.
So it's actually using
instructive to compare
with a standard-- actually, I
forgot to use this blackboard.
Anyway.
Yeah.
So [INAUDIBLE] to compare
with Minkowski spacetime,
so this compare
with Minkowski case.
So, in the Minkowski case,
if you have a free particle,
say, if you have a free massive
scalar field-- so of course,
we know this is our
equation motion, OK?
And from here, if you go
to the Minkowski space,
every direction is
translation variant,
then you just get this
dispersion relation.
You just get this
You can write phi equals
to mass at omega t.
Let me just write it
more carefully here.
You can write phi
[INAUDIBLE] omega t plus ikx.
Then plug it in.
Then you find for omega
squared equal to m
squared plus k squared.
So in Minkowski
spacetime we don't
allow m squared to be smaller
than 0 because if m squared is
smaller than 0, then that
means, for certain range of k,
say for k, for those values
of k which are smaller
than the absolute value
of m squared, then
this will be negative.
So for those things, the omega
will be purely imaginary.
You can be plus minus
purely imaginary.
And then you plug it in here.
Then you find it in
phi and typically
have exponential omega t plus
exponential minus omega t.
So the phi can have
these two behaviors.
And then, of course, this
will exponentially grow.
So this tells you that
the magnitude of phi
will exponentially
grow with time.
And so that indicated
this instability.
So this is the same as the
analog I said earlier before.
In the Minkowski spacetime,
if you have a mass squared,
and then your scalar field
one wants to slide down,
and this just tells you the
behavior wants to increase.
So this the phi.
So this is V phi.
Then the phi wants to increase.
So this is phi to 0.
But in AdS, something
nicer happens.
So in AdS, the instability only
sets in if the mass squared
becomes sufficiently
[INAUDIBLE].
So if you just have the
[INAUDIBLE] mass squared,
if it's greater than this
value, it's still OK.
It's still OK.
So the reason is
actually very simple.
So the reason is very simple.
You can try to convince yourself
by looking at the equations.
And you can see the
physics from the equations.
But the basic physical
reason is following.
In AdS, so you can just
look at that equation.
Because of the
spacetime curvature--
so the constant modes
are not allowed.
So you see here, the
most dangerous modes
are the constant modes.
And when you have
constant modes,
and then m squared becomes--
no matter how small it is,
no matter how small m squared
is, if you have constant modes,
and constant mode means
k equal to 0, then
that means that omega squared
will always be negative.
As far as m squared is
nonzero in the negative,
there's always constant
mode which is unstable.
But in AdS, because of
the spacetime curvature,
the constant mode
is not allowed.
So you always have some kind
of kinetic term in the sense
that you always have some
kind of kinetic energy.
So a field is forced to have
some kinetic energy, which
can compensate this
negative m squared.
But this won't happen when
the mass becomes too negative.
And then you have instability.
Then you have instability.
I suggest to you-- so
this is just words,
but those words can be
reflected by looking
at the structure
of those equations
and try to get some
feeling about these
by looking at those equations
a little bit more carefully.
OK, so this is the first remark.
This is the first remark.
So the second remark,
is that we know
that the AdS have a boundary.
And the light array
which of the boundaries
in the front of time.
So this is the one
important feature
we discussed at the
beginning, which
is the boundary in
the finite time.
In fact, in the AdS, it's just
pi over 2 in the finite time.
So that means,
actually, energy can
be exchanged on the boundary.
Essentially, you can send
stuff in or send things out.
And so we actually need to
impose the-- so in order
to have a sensible
physical system,
you need to impose
appropriate boundary
conditions between appropriate
boundary conditions.
So the most important
basic criterion-- again we
are not going to the detail.
And again, [? Nabil's ?]
notes discussed this
because he has to-- in order
to discuss instability,
he has also to discuss the
boundary condition, et cetera.
And you can look at
[? Nabil's ?] notes.
So basic criterion to impose
a right boundary condition is
to make sure that your
energy is conserved
and that your energy don't
dissipate into nothing,
don't dissipate at the
boundary so that you
have a well-defined system.
Good.
So now.
So when you do
canonical quantization,
then what do you do
is that you expand phi
in terms of a complete
set of normalizable modes.
Of course they also have to be
no normalizable as, normally,
in the quantum mechanics,
normalizable modes which
satisfies the appropriate
boundary condition.
So before talking about the
explicit boundary condition,
let me first mention that
issue of normalizability.
So to talk about
normalizability,
you have to devalue
in the product.
So here we have the standard
inner product for quantum field
series in the curved spacetime.
So here we have the
standard inner product.
And let me just write it down.
So this is not specific to AdS.
This just works for any
quantum field theory,
for any free scalar field
series in the curved spacetime.
So, for that series,
you can define
an inner product that follows.
So consider.
You have two modes, phi1, phi2.
And then the inner product can
be defined as the following.
You choose a constant
the time slice.
You have to choose
a constant time
slice, which I called sigma t.
So this is a constant slice.
By time, I really
mean this time.
You choose a
constant time slice.
And then, of course,
you integrate
over spatial coordinates on
these constant time slice.
So this is the inner product.
So this is the
standard inner product.
And you just plug in the
AdS metric that gives you
the explicit form for the AdS.
So if you're not
familiar with this,
and you can check
that this makes sense,
that by showing that, actually,
this thing is actually
independent of t, so
it does not depend,
actually, your time slice.
Because you don't want to your
definition of inner product
depend on specific
time you choose.
Then the normalizable would
be the standard condition,
whether this thing is finite,
or infinity, et cetera.
And you plug-in some
modes with itself.
And if it is finite,
then it's normalizable.
And if it's infinite, then
it's not normalizable.
So now this is our
symptotic behavior.
And you can check yourself,
you can also convince yourself
that the most dangerous behavior
because the metric diverges
near the boundary.
So the most dangerous
part of this integral
is near the boundary because
your metric diverges there.
And you can just
plug this behavior
and this metric behavior.
And then just pay attention to
the behavior near the boundary.
Then you can decide which
mode is normalizable,
which mode is non-normalizable.
Then you find, again, this
takes you a few minutes to do.
So you'll not do it here.
So I will only talk
about the real nu.
From now on.
Just real nu.
It means that we always
satisfy that bound.
So we find that, for that mode,
so this mode always goes to 0.
So you have these two modes.
This mode always goes to
0 because delta is always
positive because nu is
positive, and nu is non-active,
and d minus t over
2 is positive.
So this is always goes to 0.
And you can show that this
is always normalizable.
OK.
So there's no divergence
at the boundary.
But for these
modes, you're going
to see these modes
become dangerous when
the mass become very large.
When the mass becomes very
large, then the nu is big.
When nu is big, eventually
the delta can be pretty big.
And then can be greater than d.
And then this will be
an active exponent.
And then this will blow up.
So it turns out this is actually
non-normalizable indeed.
So this is non-normalizable
for nu to be greater than 1.
You actually don't
need to for, mass
to be very large,
because for nu to be
greater than or equal to 1, this
is already non-normalizable.
But it's an interesting thing.
You said this mode
is also normalizable
when nu is in this range.
Good.
Any questions?
Yes
AUDIENCE: Can we define
inner product some other way?
HONG LIU: No, this
is the only way.
This is the canonical way,
just generic for quantum field
theory in the curved spacetime.
This is not specific AdS.
Yeah, essentially, this is a
unique one, yeah I would say.
AUDIENCE: So I'm just trying
to understand inner product.
In the case that I take,
make it a norm in the sense
that I take inner product
of a field by itself.
So why, for example,
should this be positive?
HONG LIU: No, no this is
in general not positive.
In general, this is a what we
know in the Klein-Gordon field,
say, if you do in the Minkowski
spacetime, this in general, not
positive definite.
AUDIENCE: Right, sure.
HONG LIU: Yeah, same thing
in the Klein-Gordon fields.
Yeah, but the
[INAUDIBLE] is, so that
means this thing
does not make sense
to interpolate as a probability.
But you can still use this as a
definition of normalizability.
AUDIENCE: So it still
does the property
that something will
only have so it's not
a semi-norm in the sense--
like it is actually
a good inner product?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Isn't it
this it just the
generalization of probability
current of [INAUDIBLE]?
HONG LIU: Yeah, no,
this is the same
as the Klein-Gordon equation.
This is the same
inner product as you
would define for the
Klein-Gordon field,
a free massive scalar field
in Minkowski spacetime.
And that this is just
the generalization
to a general curved spacetime.
Good.
So now, yeah, so we see that
this is always normalizable.
And this sometimes is
normalizable and sometimes not
normalizable.
So now, let me talk about
the boundary conditions.
So for the time
reason, I will not
show that the boundary condition
I'm going to talk about
will give you a well-defined
energy in the sense
that there's no energy
exchange at the boundary.
And for that, take a look
at [? Nabil's ?] notes.
I will not go into
detail on that.
But the boundary condition I
say will satisfy that property.
So let's first look at when nu
is greater than or equal to n.
In this case, the
answer is obvious.
You don't even need to check
the energy conservation.
Because you only have one
possibility because this mode
is non-normalizable.
And a non-normalizable mode,
you cannot keep them when you do
the quantization.
Quantization, you have to
use normalizable modes.
So the boundary
condition you have
to choose in order that conical
quantization is equal to 0.
So you should only keep this
mode of a nu equal to 1.
Because this is
non-normalizable.
So now, when nu
is in this range,
so both modes are normalizable,
but you cannot choose both
of them.
You cannot allow both of
them because then it leads
to the non-conversation.
You need to put some
boundary conditions there.
So then, naturally, the equal
to 0 also works in this range.
So this is called the
standard quantization.
You can still impose, even
though the A modes become
normalizable, you can
still impose A equal is 0.
So tentatively you can
also impose B equal to 0.
Just take one of them.
Because A now is normalizable.
So this is called the
alternative quantization.
So sometimes, it's also possible
to impose the mixed boundary
condition between them--
to impose a mixed boundary
condition.
I will not go into there.
Anyway, so for example, if you
look at [? Nabil's ?] notes,
you can easily check for
those boundary conditions
that there's no energy
flux, through the boundary.
So, from now on, I will use
the following terminology.
From now on, we'll use
So from now on, when
I say normalizable,
I always say the mode which
are picked by quantization, OK?
So when I say normalizable,
in this case, of course,
this is normalizable.
When I say normalizable,
for nu greater than 1,
it's no ambiguity,
just the B mode.
And when nu is between 0
and 1, the normalizable
refers to the mode which
you choose to quantize.
And then the other you consider
to be non-normalizable.
Is it clear, the terminology?
So in the standard quantization,
the B-mode is normalizable,
and the A is non-normalizable,
even though, mathematically, A
is normalizable.
And in the alternative
quantization,
the B is non-normalizable,
even though, mathematically, it
is normalizable.
So normalizable would mean,
the behavior specified.
I'll call the other modes
non-normalizable modes.
So with this
terminology, I always
have 1 normalizable mode,
one non-normalizable modes.
OK, let's move on
a little bit more.
So this is the second remark.
And the third remark--
let me just erase this.
So the third remark,
so normalizable modes,
by definition, is the one we use
to do a canonical quantization.
And it's the one we use to
build up of the Hilbert space.
But now, since we have an
equivalence between the two
series, the Hilbert
space of the two series
will be the same because,
otherwise, the state of the two
series should be the same.
Otherwise, we cannot talk
about the equivalence.
So that means that any
normalizable mode, so anything
which fall off, say,
as, for example,
in the standard quantization,
like z to the powers delta
at infinity near
the boundary, you
should consider as mapped to
some states of the boundary
theory.
So this is, actually, a
very general statement.
So this will also work if you
include those higher order
corrections which are
suppressed by kappa.
So, in general, you can
apply it to a complicated
interacting nonlinear
series in the gravity side.
And the normalizable
modes are always
the modes which are in your
Hilbert space in the gravity
side.
And so that means the
mass corresponding
to some states in the
boundary field series.
Good.
So now, let's look
at the interpretation
of the non-normalizable modes.
Non-normalizable
modes, suddenly they
are not part of
the Hilbert space.
So if they are present,
in particular--
let me just finish this.
then we'll say it.
So, if present, it should be
considered-- so sometimes,
they're just not present.
But, if in some situations,
they are present,
then you should view
them, view such kind
of non-normalizable modes--
if I'm in the background.
So by background, for
example, the AdS, pure AdS,
which we are expanding
around is our background.
Yeah.
So you can imagine,
say, [INAUDIBLE]
non-normalizable
modes deform the AdS,
then you have a new background,
then you have a new background.
And in that
background, you're not
supposed to quantize
the cell, because these
are non-normalizable modes.
These are
non-normalizable modes.
AUDIENCE: Yes, sorry,
I guess I didn't quite
get the terminology
normalizable for 2, I guess?
You mentioned it, but
could you repeat it?
HONG LIU: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Normalizable,
not normalizable.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Normalizable means the behavior
specified by the quantization.
AUDIENCE: So I don't think--
I don't quite understand--
HONG LIU: Yeah,
let me just repeat.
For nu greater than
1, normalizable, it's
just normalizable, because
there's only one normalizable
mode.
For nu between 0 and 1,
mathematically, both modes
become normalizable.
But when we quantize them, and
we [INAUDIBLE] one of them.
OK?
As I said, in order to preserve
the energy conservation-- so
we have to select one of them.
So there are two possibilities.
You select the
standard quantization,
which you said A
equals to 0, you
said, the alternative
quantization
you set B equal to 0.
So the 1 you set 0
is considered to be
non-normalizable in
this terminology.
And the 1 you
allowed, which means
the one you are used to expand
as a canonical connotation
are called normalizable.
I will elaborate this
a little bit more.
Yeah.
Yeah, after five minutes,
then you will see.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What do you mean by
the other ones being present?
If we don't quantize
them, have they appeared?
HONG LIU: Yeah, they can appear.
I will, again,
explain in one minute.
So now, I'm going to make a
connection for this statement
to the statement we
are making last time.
We're making last time.
So last time we said, if a
gravity field has a boundary
value, then this
boundary value can
be considered as a source
multiply the operator which
you can add to a Lagrangian.
You can add to the action.
And so this is
precisely like that.
It's precisely like that.
So let me just repeat.
Say, let's consider the
standard quantization just
to be specific and say
standard quantization.
In this case, the
non-normalizable mode
corresponding to
A not equal to 0,
so if the non-normalizable
modes are present,
and this is corresponding
to A not equal to 0.
And we see from here,
this term, A term,
always dominated the other term.
So, in other words, when you
go to the boundary limit,
it's the A which determines the
boundary value of the field.
Let me just say.
The A, which is determined
boundary value of the field.
I put the code.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: A equal to 0 when you
do the canonical quantization.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK. [INAUDIBLE]
HONG LIU: But A
equal to 0, you mean
this is the condition in
the normalizable modes.
So here, we are discussing
the interpretation
of the non-normalizable mode.
So, now, suppose A is nonzero.
Suppose a non-normalizable
mode is non-zero.
Suppose, now, the
non-normalizable mode
is non-zero.
We are down with
normalizable modes.
This is a condition for
the normalizable modes.
OK?
So since this term
dominates, the A
should be interpolated as a
boundary value of the fields.
And if you have a non-zero A,
so if you have a non-zero A,
say, if A x is
equal to some phi x,
according to what we
discussed last time,
now up to this kinematic
factor, this thing,
which you need to strip away
because this just determines
your equation motion.
So if A equal to
5 equal to 0, that
implies that the boundary series
action should contain the term.
So what this means is
that the non-normalizable,
there are certainly not
part of the Hilbert space.
If they are present,
they actually
determine the boundary
theory itself.
So the non-normalizable modes
determine the boundary theory
itself.
So we will later see
examples of this.
But let me just repeat, so
if you look at the gravity
solution, then you look
at its symptotic behavior
near the boundary.
And if you see-- let's,
say, consider two solutions,
two different solutions.
If the two different
solutions have
the same non-normalizable
behavior--
say the non-normalizable
modes are the same, but only
the difference in the
normalizable modes,
then you will say these
two solutions describe
two states of the same theory.
Because they only differ
by normalizable modes.
Then it describes the different
states in the same theory.
But now, if I look at
two such solutions,
and these two solutions
differ by the behavior
of the non-normalizable
modes, then we would say,
these two solutions
corresponding
to two different
series because one
is due to two different series.
Because non-normalizable modes
needs to add additional terms
to your boundary theory action.
Have I answered your questions?
AUDIENCE: So basically, you
just assume any field which is
a type of-- maybe a
combination of those two modes,
but if the--
HONG LIU: Forget about linear
combination of the modes.
Just say, if you consider two
solutions, which if there only
differ by normalizable
modes, then they
correspond to different
states of the same theory.
And if they differ by
non-normalizable modes,
that means they describe
different theories.
Even the theories they
describe are different.
And so that's why we
call this background.
We call this background because
the symptotic conditions
at infinity has changed.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
So, in the alternative
standard upon the quantization
case that-- which
would be equal to 0.
HONG LIU: Right.
AUDIENCE: But we know that
the d minus delta is always
larger than delta.
But in that case, it
seems near the boundary.
The boundary determines,
not the number.
HONG LIU: Right, right.
Yeah.
That's a very good question.
So that, you have to
stretch a little bit.
Yeah.
Good?
So let me finish my last
equation before we break.
So more precisely,
because of this z term,
so in the standard
quantization, yeah
let me just write it
there, so write it here.
Let me just replace this one.
In the standard
quantization, if you
have such a term in your
boundary series Lagrangian,
that's corresponding to this
phi x is equal to limit z
goes to 0, z to the power
delta minus d phi zx.
So I have to multiply a
power so that it will just
extract this A factor from
the behavior of the phi.
And the so this is the relation.
So this is the
important relation.
So, last time, we
only said that phi
should corresponding to the
boundary value of this capital
phi.
But now, by working out
the symptotic behavior,
we have refined that statement.
Now it's a really precise
mathematical statement.
Any questions regarding this?
AUDIENCE: Is it a guess or--
HONG LIU: No, this is
just a [INAUDIBLE].
This limit precisely
extracts this A term.
This term, because that opposite
power to this one, and this one
will be smaller.
This one will be smaller because
that multiplier, this one, when
z goes to 0 will go to 0.
So you automatically
extract this term.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HONG LIU: It's just
this statement.
The A is related to this.
OK.
AUDIENCE: No, this statement
is a guess from the example
we discussed last time.
So last time, by looking
at this line example,
we deduce that the
boundary value of a field
should be related to the source.
The boundary value of
a [INAUDIBLE] field
should be related to the
source of a boundary operator.
And at that time, we don't
know what we mean, precisely,
by boundary value.
And now we have worked out a
precise symptotic behavior.
And now you can talk about what
you mean by boundary behavior.
And then that refines
that statement
to that precise
mathematical statement.
Good.
So let's start.
So let's see what we can
deduce from this relation.
So turns out that there's a
very important information you
can deduce from this equation.
And this is my number five.
So let me call
this equation star.
So this equation
star, relation star,
actually tells you that this
delta, which defined before,
in this way, and appears
in your symptotic formula
like this, this
delta is actually,
it's the scaling dimension of
the operator dual to phi of O.
So we're assuming this phi
is due to some operator
O in the boundary.
And so this is actually
this precise in the scaling
dimension of O. So now,
let me explain that.
So before I do this, do
you have any questions?
Good.
OK, so let me first
remind you how
we define the scaling
dimension of an operator
in conformal field theory.
So if you have a scaling
[INAUDIBLE] theory,
then the overall
scaling is a symmetry.
So such a scaling is a symmetry.
And so under such
symmetry transformation,
say, operator, we call
it a scaling operator
if you transform.
And under this symmetry
has the following.
So transform into a
new operator prime.
And evaluated at
the new x prime is
equal to just
differ by a scaling
from the previous operator.
OK, so we pause.
So the operator, with such
property, a scaling operator.
So good operators, which
are representations
of the conformal symmetry
always have this behavior.
And this delta defines
the scaling dimension.
So this delta is the
scaling dimension.
So this is the definition
of the scaling dimension.
So this is almost similar
to a scalar field.
So a scalar field means
that the new scalar field,
you evaluate it at a new point.
It should be the same as
your old scalar field.
You evaluate it
at the old point.
And here the difference
is just of a pre-factor.
And this number defines
the scalar information.
Good?
So now I will derive that
this relation implies
that this operator
transforms precisely
according to this delta.
So let me first I remind you
that the boundary scaling x mu
goes to x mu prime
equal to lambda
x mu is related
to the bark, also
to isometry, which is the x
mu prime equal to lambda x mu.
But, at the same time,
you also scale z.
So this scaling
symmetry, the counterpart
of this scaling in
the gravity side
is that you scale
both of them together.
And the gravity metric
is invariant under this.
So now let's consider
transformation.
So now let's consider the
relation between the phi x
z and the O x.
So let's consider such a
transformation on both sides.
So on the gravity side,
such a transformation
leads to a new field.
And this should be dual
to transform the field
on the field theory side.
AUDIENCE: Which [INAUDIBLE]
HONG LIU: Yeah, that's right.
Yeah.
That's right.
Now, this is [INAUDIBLE].
This is a boundary.
OK?
But I think, since
this is a symmetry,
so this transformation of both
symmetries in the field series
side on the gravity side, that
should have low consequences.
That should have
low consequence.
That means.
And the phi prime, this mu
phi is the boundary value
of the corresponding
capital phi, OK?
This should still be the same
because your physics should not
be changed under this.
So now let me remind you
that phi is a scalar field.
In the gravity side,
this is a scalar fields.
So scalar fields
transform, under such
a coordinate transformation,
transforms as phi prime,
X prime, z prime.
You go to phi x z.
So this is just the
definition of the scalar
field in the gravity site.
And now let's apply this
to the boundary value.
Then we find that the phi prime
x, which is a boundary value
capital phi prime, so this
should be equal to that.
So now we use that this relation
of z prime is lambda times Z.
And this is just equal to that.
So this just becomes lambda
to the delta minus t phi x.
Clear?
So now you can just plug
this back into here.
So there's a factor of
lambda minus delta minus d.
And this comes with a factor of
lambda to the power d and then
tells you that O prime
x prime equal to lambda
minus delta O x.
And we show that this
delta, which appears here,
or, whatever, here,
is that delta.
It's the dimension
of the operator.
AUDIENCE: But in
standard quantization,
you mentioned that--
HONG LIU: No, this is a
standard quantization.
AUDIENCE: A equals 0 in
HONG LIU: No, no, we're
talking about the source.
We're talking about
non-normalizable modes.
We're not talking about
canonical quantization.
We're talking about attending
non-normalizable modes,
because when we're adding
on such a term to action.
AUDIENCE: But isn't that a
field operator correspondence?
HONG LIU: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Isn't that a field
operator correspondence?
HONG LIU: Yeah, this is.
AUDIENCE: But these
are non-normalizable.
HONG LIU: Yeah, that's
what we, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
So we're talking about the
non-normalizable modes.
And the non-normalizable
modes corresponding
to [INAUDIBLE] operator,
and [INAUDIBLE] source
into an operator in
the boundary series.
And just this relation shows
that delta is this dimension.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: So then, when
we quantize everything,
this operator O is dual to
normalizable [INAUDIBLE],
or non-normalizable?
HONG LIU: No.
Here we are talking
about the question-- here
we're talking
about this relation
that if there is a boundary
value of capital phi, which
is this boundary
value, then that's
corresponding to add such
a term to your Lagrangian.
And under such a
correspondence, then we
deduce that this delta is the
dimension of this operators.
It's the dimension
of this operator.
And this is deduced from the
non-normalizable perspective.
And in indeed, you
can ask, say, suppose
I create normalizable
modes using this O,
whether that is
consistent with that.
Indeed, that you
can double check.
Is it clear?
Anyway, so this is
what we have right now.
So later, we will discuss
the correspondence
for the normalizable modes.
And we worry about later.
Later, we will talk
about the correspondence
for normalizable modes.
And then you will see it's
compatible with this relation.
So now we find, for scalar,
for a standard quantization,
for scalar, in the
standard quantization,
for scalar in the
that the dimension
of the operator
related to the mass
in the gravity side
by the following relation.
[INAUDIBLE] to [INAUDIBLE]
by this relation.
So we have found that
explicit relation
between the conformal
dimension and the mass.
So now, let me elaborate a
little bit on this relation.
So let's consider,
suppose the m equal to 0.
Well, m equal to 0, then you
find the delta equal to d.
So delta equal to d, on
the field theory side,
this is a marginal
operator, and so we
see that the massless
field on the gravity side
is mapped to a
marginal operator.
So are you familiar with
the terminology of marginal,
operator, relevant operator?
Et cetera.
Good.
AUDIENCE: Wait, can you
remind us what is it?
HONG LIU: This is defined
in terms of the RG flow.
Are you taking the
quantum field theory too?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
We haven't quite gotten
there. [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: Yeah, then you
will get there, maybe,
in a week or two.
Yeah, certainly by the
end of this semester.
Yeah, so let me
just say one-- yeah
I will say a few more words.
And then you will
see what it means.
Yeah, just I will
say a few more words.
Anyway, so will m
squared smaller than 0,
then he is negative.
Then this is d squared
over 4 matter something.
So that means the delta
is smaller than d.
When the dimension
of the operator
is smaller than the
spacetime dimension,
so that, from field
theory, according to you,
is called the relevant operator.
And now, when m squared
is greater than 0,
it's mapped to delta
greater than d,
so this is mapped to
an irrelevant operator.
AUDIENCE: Why do they
have [INAUDIBLE]?
HONG LIU: Why do they
have these names?
Marginal, relevant,
or irrelevant?
Yeah, I will say a
little bit about that.
Just wait one second.
So now, let's say what this
means from the perspective
of this relation.
So from the field
series side, we
have phi x O x mapped into-- so
this phi should be identified
we A. So this is identified
with this term, d minus delta.
OK, leading term.
OK, so now let me
remind you what
this marginal and
relevant, irrelevant means.
So operator marginal means,
when you add such a term
to your Lagrangian, the
effect of such a term
does not change with scale.
So whether you're looking
at a very high energy,
looking at very low
energy, the effect
does not change very much.
OK, so that's why it's
called a marginal operator.
So in the regulation group,
there's a very simple scaling
argument to show that, when
the delta is equal to d,
and then the effect
of the operator
does not change with the scale.
In particular, when you go to
the UV, this does not change.
For a marginal operator.
When you go UV, say, when you go
to higher and higher energies,
the effect of these operators
remains the same, roughly.
So now, we know from
this UV connection,
UV mapped on the
gravity side to z
goes to 0 means we are
approaching the boundary.
And now we see, precisely
for d equal to delta,
this term is actually constant.
So go to smaller and smaller
z, and the effect of this term
does not change.
It's just a constant.
So again, does not change.
So now, let's look at
the relevant operator.
So the relevant operator,
so in the field theory,
when you do the RG, the
relevant and the irrelevant
means, whether this term becomes
relevant when you go to the IR.
By relevant, means that the term
becomes more and more important
when you to the low energies.
So that means that, for
the relevant operator, when
you go t higher
energies, it becomes
less and less important.
By definition, the
relevant operator means,
when you go to low
energies, it becomes
more and more important.
And it means, when you
go to higher energies,
it become less and
less important.
So it means that,
when you go to UV,
the relevant operator becomes
less and less important.
So now, let's look at this side.
The relevant operator
corresponding
to delta smaller than d, then
you have a positive power.
And that means, when z goes
to 0, when you go to UV,
actually, this term goes to 0.
So this is precisely compatible
with the field theory
behavior we expect when you add
such a term to a Lagrangian.
And the effect of
such a term should
be less and less important
when you go to higher energies.
And here, we see a
precise counterpart here.
And similarly, now, if you
go through the irrelevant
operator.
Irrelevant means irrelevant
when you go to IR.
When you go to UV means
more and more important.
So that means-- but here,
when delta is greater than d,
then these here
have elective power.
So here, goes to
infinity, become
bigger and bigger
and, indeed, this term
becomes more and more important.
So we see a very
nice correspondence
between this behavior
we expect just
from the ordinary RG and
the behavior of this term
in the gravity side.
So this is a very important
self consistency check
of our matching, both of this
relation and of this relation.
Any questions on this?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What's the
topology of AdS boundary?
HONG LIU: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: What's the
topology of AdS boundary?
HONG LIU: It's a
Minkowski space.
AUDIENCE: But it's 5--
it's 5 times something.
HONG LIU: It is a
Minkowski space.
Boundary of AdS is
just Minkowski space.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
[INAUDIBLE] in RG
why [INAUDIBLE]
HONG LIU: That take
some story to do.
Yeah, that you have to do in
the quantum field theory too.
Yeah, but it's very
easy to understand
if you just know a little
bit of free field theory.
And in the field
theory point of view,
when the dimension
of this operator
is smaller than the
dimension of this operator,
and then this is
dimensional, then this
has a positive mass dimension.
And this is, like, mass term.
And the mass term becomes
more and more important
when you go to lower energies.
And that's important
because the higher energies.
Yeah, just from
dimensional analysis.
Yeah, it takes
maybe five minutes
to explain very clearly.
But we don't have
these five minutes.
OK, so let me just summarize.
So we have this relation.
Let me maybe just
summarize here.
So we have the other relation.
So summary.
So we have phi due
to go to some O.
So here, normalizable
modes should
be considered different
normalizable modes
corresponding to
different states.
And here, non-normalizable modes
is mapped to different actions.
So you have a different
non-normalizable modes,
then you map to
different actions.
You map to different series.
So in other words, map
to different series.
So when you turn on the
non-normalizable modes,
you are deforming the theory.
So just to elaborate,
just more precisely,
in the standard
quantization, which
is A modes are non-normalizable,
when the A-modes are
non-normalizable, then A x.
On the gravity side, is mapped
to this last term on the field
theory side.
If you have a non-0 x, A x
mapped to the following term
in your action.
And then your mass, we
deduce that this side
is mapped to the dimension,
give the delta dimension
of this operator O.
So later we will explain, as
part of this normalizable mode
story, so this B-- so
A is non-normalizable
but B is normalizable.
So later, as we will explain,
in the normalizable mode story,
is the B x here, we
are actually mapped
to the expectation value of O.
So B is a normalizable
mode, then, actually,
that maps to a
expectation value of O
in the corresponding states.
So A mapped to how
you deform the theory,
and the B just mapped
to the state which
specify your expectation value.
So this, we'll see later.
And in alternative quantization,
you just do it oppositely.
In alternative quantization,
you just switch A and B.
So now B maps to B x O. And A x
maps to the expectation value.
And m now maps to d minus delta.
So now, the dimension of the
operator is d minus delta
rather than delta.
So now, because you just
take the different exponents.
It's the same thing, just
take different exponents.
So now, the dimension of the
operator is d minus delta.
So now, let me also make
you some other examples.
So you can consider
gauge fields.
You can consider, say, a Maxwell
field in the gravity side.
Then that's [INAUDIBLE] dual
to some conserved currents,
so besides earlier.
And then you can
check, then again, you
just solve the Maxwell
equation, which I will not
have time to do it here.
But I may ask you to
do it in your p set.
It said A mu as z
goes to infinity
becomes-- so the path of
A parallel to the boundary
goes to a constant.
There's no z.
It's really a constant plus
b mu some number to the z
to the d minus 2.
So this is a leading behavior
in the case of the vector field.
So using the very
similar scaling argument
I was doing there,
you can deduce
that the operator due to A
must have dimension d minus 1.
This I will leave to
you as an exercise.
Just exactly parallel
statement for the scalar case.
And with this symptotic
behavior, you can show,
just using the
argument, you can show
that the operator dual to A
must have dimension d minus 1.
And this is precisely
the dimension
a conserved current must have.
So conserved current
because it's conserved.
So its dimension, it's
actually protected.
So no matter in what
kind of interaction,
no matter in what kind
of case, you always have
the same dimension d minus 1.
So this precisely
agrees with that.
So do you understand why?
AUDIENCE: Why.
HONG LIU: Yeah, the
reason is simple.
It's just because j0,
the dimension of the j0.
You can understand
the following.
The j0 is the charge density.
And the charge density
charge, by definition,
does not have a dimension.
And by definition the
density will always
have a dimension
minus 1, d minus 1.
And then the other
components, they just
follow by the conservation.
Yes, so, indeed, this is, again,
this is a consistency check.
AUDIENCE: So for
this case, there
is no choice of quantization?
HONG LIU: Yeah, there's no
choice for quantization, right.
Actually, in AdS four, in
some special dimensions,
you can also do a
different quantization.
But the story is a
little bit subtle.
In some special dimensions,
sometimes you can do it.
Yeah, in AdS four, you can do
a different boundary condition.
So now let me also
mention the stress tensor,
which is the other
important one.
And we mentioned that
the stress tensor,
which is due to the perturbation
of the metric component.
So if you write the AdS
metric as some function times
dz squared plus g
mu mu dx mu dx mu,
so this is the part
of the metric parallel
to the boundary,
then we discussed,
last time, if g mu mu goes
to the boundary as something
like this, then eta mu mu
plus some perturbation,
then that means that, in
the field theory site,
you're turning on a stress
tensor perturbation.
So that's what we
argued last time.
If the boundary value of
your [INAUDIBLE] metric, say,
is perturbed, away from
the Minkowski metric,
then corresponding from the
field theory point of view,
we turn on a source
for the stress tensor.
So again, by using
this relation,
you can deduce that
the stress tensor must
have dimension, the
corresponding operator must
have dimension d.
Again, this gives you
exercise for yourself.
And again, that is
precisely the stress tensor.
The dimension should
satisfy that stress tensor.
And again, because
the stress tensor
is a conserved
current et cetera,
always, no matter in what
kind of series always
have dimension d.
So now, after I have
discussed this relation,
let's now discuss how to compute
the correlation functions.
So let's discuss how to
compute correlation functions.
So the basic observable
in the field theory,
even more so in the
conformal field theory,
is just correlation
functions of local operators.
It's an important part
of the [INAUDIBLE].
And in the field
theory, typically,
when we can see the correlation
function of local operators,
we use something called a
generating function, though.
I hope you're
familiar with this.
Say, again, in the
rating function,
though-- so now let's
consider Euclidean,
which is a little bit simpler.
So essentially, it's a Euclidean
creating correlation function
by adding such a term
to your field theory.
And if you want to calculate
correlation functions of O,
then just take
derivative with phi
and then satisfy equal to 0.
Then you get the
correlation function of O.
So I hope you are
familiar with this.
so here, you should think of
phi and O as just some, really,
I have a collection of
all possible operators,
even though I just
write the single one.
You should think of them as a
collection of all operators.
You can put anything
here, stress
tensor, conserved current,
any scalar operator,
any spin operator.
Yeah, you can put
anything there.
So in a simpler
situation, you just
don't turn on any operator.
You just take phi equal to 0.
So this is a simpler situation.
Then you just have the
partition function.
So this correlation function is
defined by the Euclidean path
integral, for example.
And you just insert this in
the Euclidean path integral.
And when phi is equal to 0,
this is just the Euclidean path
integral.
And this is just gives
you a partition function
of the whole system.
And since we believe
the duality should be 2,
then this partition
function should
be exactly the same
as the partition
function on the gravity side.
Suppose you can
compute the partition
function from the gravity side.
Then it must be the same.
Otherwise, there's
no equivalence.
So this is the partition
function of the gravity side.
So these have to be true.
So now, with this
relation, again, we
are right in the heuristic
form that some operator O
is due to some [INAUDIBLE] phi.
And the source for the O is due
to the boundary value of phi--
again, I write in
the heuristic form.
So the boundary
value of phi should
be understood in that limit.
Because of this,
then that means we
must have-- if we turn on
a [INAUDIBLE] or a phi,
deforming the
series by this phi,
the mass corresponding to the
gravity side of the partition
function, with this phi,
have the boundary value
given by phi.
Then it must be the same
because we have identified
turning on the boundary value
to turning on the operator,
turning on this thing
in the field series.
So we have now
related the generating
functional to the
gravity partition
function with some
non-normalizable boundary
conditions.
So, in general, give
me one more minute.
So in general, this
equation is actually empty
because we don't know how
to define the gravity site.
Full quantum gravity
partition function.
What are you talking about?
If you don't know
how to do that.
But we know how to compute this
guy in the semiclassical limit,
which is the string
coupling goes to 0,
and the other prime
goes to 0 limit.
So in this limit,
we can just write
the gravity path in
function, essentially
as the Euclidean path integral
of all gravity fields.
Again, I'm using
this heuristic form
to write the boundary condition.
But it should be
understood in that form.
And again, I'm by
integrating over phi,
you should imagine integrating
of all gravity fields.
So now, in the limit, so
this SE is proportional to 1
over kappa squared, which
is the Newton constant.
So in the semiclassical
limit, in this limit,
the kappa squared goes to 0.
So you can actually
evaluate this path integral
using the site
point approximation.
So as the leading
order, so this gravity
can actually be evaluated.
So leading order in the
semiclassical limit,
you can just evaluate it by
site point approximation,
then this is just given by SE.
Evaluate it as a
classical solution
which satisfies the appropriate
boundary conditions.
So that means,
actually, in this limit,
we can actually evaluate
this explicitly.
And the nice thing
is, as we said
before, the semiclassical
limit actually
corresponding to the [INAUDIBLE]
limit in the field theory.
So we can actually
compute explicitly
the generating functional
in the [INAUDIBLE]
of the limit over
the field theory.
So let's stop here.